as debt levels in individual member  states keep rising  the eu is also finding itself in a  deepening hole of debt  faced with a widening gap between  commitments undertaken  and the real payments made meps want to  stop the hemorrhaging  meeting in the budget committee mep  scrapped the council's cuts to funding  for projects  the aim to avoid the scourge of payment  defaults  meps also decided to invest an  additional 400 million euros in external  action  160 in smes and to allocate 30 million  farmers hit hard by russian sanctions  erasmus plus was also included as a  priority  we couldn't feel me  not everyone shared this view in the  budget committee there's  next up will be a plenary vote on the  22nd of october  aiming to reach an agreement with the  council by the end of november  between austerity and investing in  priority projects a choice must be made